so Kevin for those of our listeners that
don't know who you are what's your deal
I'm a partner here at Y Combinator I
actually was in the second ever batch I
was in winter 2006 and I founded a
company called wufu ring that for five
years and then we were acquired by
SurveyMonkey and that moved us from
Florida to California and that's when PG
asked if I'd be interested in helping
out I might see I've been there pretty
much ever since yeah and you suggested
Jake as a guest for this episode so Jake
what do you do some the founder and CEO
of insight so insight is an education
company we were in now fellows programs
that help scientists and engineers
transition to careers in data science
and AI and it's a pretty unique model
because they're completely free these
fellowships they're full time the
companies sort of fund the the process
engineer scientists build projects for
four seven weeks
they meet top data teams and they get
hired on those teams we've got over
2,000 insight alumni working as data
scientists now across the u.s. and
Canada nice and you always haven't been
working on this so you applied to IC for
the winter 2011 bat that's right yeah
and what was your idea then so I was I
was back in sum I started my career and
this this is relevant to why I started
insight cuz I basically started I wish I
wish I'd access to when I was around I
was a physicist yeah at the University
of Toronto I thought it was gonna be
scientists for this in my life and then
partway through my PhD I realized I want
to go into technology and I think to
myself I'm writing code I'm building
machine learning models this is great
I've got I've got what I need and it
frankly took me a long time to
transition eventually got into Y
Combinator came down here from the
winter 11 batch I was building a bunch
of time mobile Mobile sort of
productivity apps that were machine
learning enabled and and didn't quite
get the up into the right graph that you
would hope for after all I see but it
was an incredible experience and you
know in those sort of in that sort of
late 2011 after called 6 12 12 months
after YC was searching for a new idea
and actually went spoke with Paul Graham
and a few other advisors and the
recommendation was work on a problem you
self-avowed you're kind of building
these apps that you know you're trying
to use these machine learning models and
hopefully somebody's got that as a
problem but flip it around start with a
problem you
then figure out what the solution is and
when I reflected on it it took me a few
years to really make this transition
I've been so close all along but I
didn't know product I wasn't really
connected in the valley there's a bunch
of you know technically I had the
fundamentals but a lot of tool sets were
different in the industry so I didn't
know what I didn't know and when I got
down here and I started talking to
people that's when I finally started
figuring it out and was seeing a lot of
my friends having that same struggle so
brilliant you know mathematicians
neuroscientists biologists also
engineers later we found the same thing
kind of getting stuck and like they're
like I want to go into data science I
want to go into AI want to go into these
cutting-edge fields but you know it
doesn't say the right thing on my resume
or I'm kind of like you know just
getting that last mile is really hard to
to cross and I thought okay well this is
a problem I want to solve mmm because
these are some of the most brilliant
people I'd ever worked with a lot of
them were my former colleagues from
physics and I thought what is the
solution for this look like and at first
I was focused on it's gonna be an app
again right it's something machine
learning and able app and then I
realized now it actually probably looks
more like an in person program where
folks are getting together building cool
projects and then getting started from
there and so did you just go ahead and
teach a class yeah so I basically you
know started talking first I talked to
companies and I said listen I've got
these brilliant friends coming out of
academia who I think you should be
hiring why aren't you hiring them and
basically what they told me is I know
they're brilliant I know they've got the
all these skills great skills but
they're probably like one to two months
away of from where I need them to be in
terms of if I had full days to mentor
them for a month or two they'd be an
incredible data scientist but they're
like I don't have a month or two to
mentor them so I say no in the interview
right and so I'm like why of a month or
two so maybe what insight is going to be
is that month or two where folks are
filling in this last piece of the puzzle
learning the the sort of cutting edge
techniques and sort of tool sets and
other things and then let's bring those
data scientists in the room and have
them hire and anything ever just jump
right in and I and I ran the first
session see me that first session was
just me first student so the focus with
it were PhDs so that first group was in
2012
like you're wrong this no no I mean I
had to go beyond my friends so at first
I started talking my friends in academia
so that you know I got confirmation from
my friends in academia that you had I
mean I already knew that they were
looking for jobs and they were excited
about transitioning I got confirmation
from the hiring managers to say listen
we're hiring we can't find folks with
the full skill set if you bring them
into a room what we'll go look at them
and then the rest was kind of because
you mentioned that you didn't know what
you didn't know yeah
and so I that time I had spent like
three years figuring it out including
doing YC and meeting a much data
scientist and building a bunch of data
products so you know by that point I
kind of knew what the pieces were but
also really the program was focused not
on me teaching the fellows it was
focused on me bringing in the sort of
leading day scientist at the time and
putting them directly tell them so we
had you know you know Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter Square all these early data
teams in 2012 their heads of data
science come in so they were only like
one day they just couldn't commit like
yeah yeah that's exactly that's exactly
if they're like okay I'll come in for a
few hours but I don't have two months
and I'm like well if I have a bunch of
you come in for a few hours plus you
know really have these folks kind of
working away for a few months learning
from each other learning from these
mentors once we had alumni to is
incredible we had all these alumni
coming in to help
it's like it was that first class cycle
it was eight fellows and then how many
of them did you get them jobs pretty
much yeah yeah 100% yeah yeah one went
to Facebook went to square won't to
LinkedIn one went to Twitter I mean at
the time these was like they still are
the top data see but I mean it was it
was it was a clear success it was super
stressful I didn't know the model I had
hadn't figured it out it was crazy I
mean what mistakes did you make like was
that first class kind of a [ __ ] show of
course in the sense that in the sense
that it was the first time I was doing
it and a lot of it a career transition
is always stressful whenever people are
doing insight they're stressed but at
least there's a track record there and
now we have things baked pretty well at
that time the overall idea was there but
the a lot of the details weren't there
right and so and frankly the track
record wasn't there so a lot of these
folks are like what have I done I'm in a
room with this guy who's never done this
before
so there there's a lot of stress just
around is this even gonna work this
weird model um what I'm trying to say is
like but we made it work what is that
what is like like what did those eight
students believe right like were they
desperate or like were you great at
sales no no I think I think they're
they're genuinely excited like we part
of the application process I got way
more applications I expected and when I
started it there's a real demand to get
into the field I didn't have a track
record but I basically went around to
these universities and said I'm gonna
have the head of data science from
Facebook LinkedIn Twitter all these
companies coming in and you're gonna
meet them so the roster can fill up more
guts right yeah and they were in my
interview process really centered around
how excited you're about this for the
folks who are like I really don't want
to do this but I need a plan B no thank
you right it was the people who are who
said to me I love my work as an as a
scientist but I really want to kind of
move have a kind of more of an applied
impact in the world I'm excited but what
I'm seeing here here's what I think I
could do I mean that's kind of folks I
would take into the program mm-hmm
totally makes sense starting off with
like qualifying the lead it's such a
more common technique you're seeing a
lot of syrups do now like superhuman for
example yeah heavily qualifying a lay
before they'll even let them access to
the product so that way you're trying to
guarantee that like the time I do spend
absolutely someone that's like gonna
have a spectacular
yeah that's why this how did you these
higher mansion want to come in how did
you figure out what students were going
to be the most excited about this like
what do you ask them yeah so I mean I
had some opinions but really what I did
is I went to these early heads of data
science teams and said what do you look
for and what they said is like you know
the list off some technical skills but
you know it's kind of like Glaser you
know they need to know sequel they need
to know Python they need to know and you
know and it's like I'm like okay but
what really like would like clinch it
for you like they update like you want
this person and there's two things
always there's like they have a side
project hmm and in their eyes would
light up they'd go oh they had a side
project if you send me a URL oh my god I
know they're excited then I know they're
and so that's where the idea came around
for hey this isn't about you know these
folks have been through enough class
it's about actually building for it
actually creating something improving
that I've got all these great background
but now I'm gonna do this last piece of
the puzzle to show you I can do
something relevant in this area and the
second thing that they wanted and I
think this is where the project really
shows this but they wanted overall is
just curiosity so folks and I thought
that they weren't being serious to be
honest with you because I was like yeah
you say you want curiosity really you
just want somebody's good at like sequel
or something right yeah or good at like
machine learning and it proved to be
true the people they were hire would be
the ones who were the people who hey I
studied astrophysics but in my spare
time I was like come dabbling with
genomics and then I got into machine
learning on the side and then I built
this cool for fun project that like I
don't know predicts like where I should
go to you know camping or something cuz
I'm a big camper or something and then
you take a person like that and that's
the kind of folks that these teams want
wanted and still want because these
problems are so open-ended well it's
like theater is curious people don't get
blocked as much right they're willing to
try this and you know it's such a new
field the the the rules are our fellows
are getting hired into most of the
companies it's not like we know what you
we need you to do just do it yeah it's
what can we even do here right what can
we what kind of impact our data again
how did you ask how did you test for
that like curia I think the project
seems like okay that's something we have
to shoot for but again it's like how did
you know that these were that right
eight people well so you know it's a lot
of trial and error I would do like
twelve plus interviews a day and kind of
you kind of get to know folks and kind
of get to know it but I think the main
thing the signal that I saw was it's
kind of that example I gave is that
almost a people would be almost
apologetic they'd be like listen what
I'm about to tell you is not part of my
my usual work but it's on the side and
it's like no no I want to hear about
that I remember had this one of the
fellows came what she became a fellow
but she was an early session
mathematician at Berkeley and she had
done all this incredible analysis I
can't quite remember what like this
really cool data analysis project I
think I'm like maybe flight times or
something in sports I can't quite
remember and part way through the
interview I'm like but you're
mathematician like don't you try pencil
and paper math yeah excuses I've done
some math she's like oh yeah I'd like a
camera or what the
she's like oh yeah this is this is not
even part of my and she almost felt kind
of apologetic I was like this is who I
want as a fella right brilliant
mathematician doing incredible work and
able to on the side on the weekend
quickly pick up Python this got the
other make something useful she went on
it what she worked at is continues to
work at Facebook she went to Facebook
after the program been super successful
the other since so it's people like that
that you're like I want you so this
isn't related to one of these like
overarching questions we had for you so
basically it's like how can people get
into data science and then what are the
pitfalls for people who say have a PhD
you know they know Python they're like
at a higher level than like a coding
bootcamp person yeah what are the
pitfalls they make when they're trying
to bridge that gap and get into a data
science role provided that they didn't
do your program yeah absolutely and we
see it because we you know I started
with scientists and now we also have
programs for engineers yeah
transitioning to machine learning
engineering deep learning research and
you sort of see very similar problem on
both sides which is folks are extremely
focused on the the sort of technical let
me get the algorithmic knowledge down
let me know every last algorithm which
of course you need and you need those
foundations yeah
but when you're already dealing with
someone who has you know been doing a
bunch of work for years in a PhD or in
engineering in these areas what you
actually want to see in what these teams
want to see is communication ability its
ability to understand the underlying
like business and product problem
because what they want to do is hire
someone who's gonna first think about
what are we trying to accomplish here
how can we help our users how can we
help our company succeed and then figure
out how do I use my tool set of machine
learning or analysis to do it and what
often happens and this is the pitfall is
you know part of why you get into it is
because you're excited to be at an ALICE
excited about the the machine learning
and so you start always putting that
first and you're always like let me tell
you the algorithm so i can build and
it's like what what what folks need to
start who are trying to transition into
it need to start think about product
need to start to think about business
need to ask like the skills there's like
what are they actually try making them a
better salesperson and what what's
interesting about the advice that we
give to a lot of people right
else's like it's not about selling your
own thing is understanding their problem
then I complete it and then you're
feeding whatever you have into them and
so it seems like for the data science
the same thing is happened it's not a
right here's all the things I have right
it's like try to figure out what it is
that you fit into you for them exactly
right and it's like understand the
underlying forget data forget machine
learning oliver's what are we trying to
accomplish here what's our mission what
are we trying to do it for our users and
then like making yourself look like the
solution not trying to be like oh I have
a bunch of stuff which one of these
things are you interested exactly I put
the hammer and screwdriver like which
like I can use all of its like what are
we trying to build here yes and
sometimes that's actually a separate
role so for instance say like Facebook
might list a data science job yeah where
is some you know smaller startup would
say like we're we have an engineering
role open writing you might classify
yourself as a data scientist if you have
to pitch data science to a start-up
right how do you do that as a writer
this is a great question so first of all
data science machine learning these are
all like super broad umbrella terms it's
such a new field yes maybe you should
define maybe a while these defined data
science and and I think I think this is
this is gonna this is essentially
answering your question which is so what
we see in the industry kind of broadly
speaking broad terms details let's not
worry about the details it's sort of I
see you got three big pieces of how sort
of data science is used so some data
science roles are what I kind of called
product analytics or business analytics
roles the idea there is you're looking
for a better understand you're analyzing
data about users or company and trying
to understand how to improve it mmm-hmm
help users succeed help the business
succeed the second types of roles that
we see are data product roles so these
are roles where you're actually using
machine learning and predictive models
to actually change the user experience
and give them something they want as
right right there and then as part of
the product and the third one is kind of
you know usually what you hear termed as
like AI which is you know AI roles
machine learning engineering roles where
it's not just a feature in the product
like that's the prediction it's like the
product is machine learning right like
it's like a like a self-driving car like
if that doesn't if this if the
she learning doesn't work like the whole
product doesn't work and so you'll have
an example of a lot of things
misunderstanding which one we're not a
category in between where it's like oh
machine learning like supplements a
feature yeah or offense yeah yeah so
usually that's where folks talk about
data products so when they talk about
data products often like a feature so
like the Netflix recommendation engine
that's a situation where honestly if
they didn't have machine learning they
could still just say like here the top
movie is go watch him yeah
but with that predictive model you're
really getting a much better experience
and so what we have probably 30-plus
fellows working at Netflix a lot of them
work on that stuff but some of them work
on analytics which is how are people
even using this this product what can we
add a more product level do to improve
it and and they're the output isn't a
feature that the user sees like like a
actual algorithm serving recommendations
there it's like they have to go and
communicate with the product team to say
hey users seem to want us to be building
this sort of product for them let's over
the next six to 12 months take the
product in that direction it's like a
very different role here's an
interesting question so I know like what
the dream scenario for a lot of data
scientists are like I want to get a job
work on these interesting problems right
like what should they look out for that
they should avoid in a company like like
water what is a company uses because I
think everyone's kind of thinking yeah
or more than should is like looking for
a data scientist and I should add a
design just be worried about this like
oh they're not ready to actually hire me
and if I go here this will be a bad
experience we see wrong I said the data
scientist needs to know what the actual
problem is your company needs to know
what the actual problem is and so the
companies need to be wary that are the
ones where it's like hey I you know what
just like I want deep learning and it's
like what what what does that mean what
do you want us to do here and why do you
need it in the company you want to go to
is the one that's got it got a mission
you aligned with you want to see them
succeed you want to have whatever
solution to bring to the market you know
thrive in the world and then they have a
clear sense of if we add some data
analysis to this if we add machine
learning this it's going to be better
and then you can help them get there so
someone from Twitter asks this Chuck
Graham a test when you know or when do
you know you need to bring in seasoned
data scientists
so like is there any kind of benchmark
you can offer yeah I think I'm so first
of all I think you have to start as a
founder start with the idea and you can
do this
I recommend this before you have a data
scientist understand is data sort of
critical to my to building my product or
is it something that I'll just add on
once it's already working and I need to
kind of optimize the experience so you
know an example an example for sort of
something critical is like Amazon Alexa
right like if you're building Alexa like
that those algorithms voice recognition
analysis better work from day one versus
a scenario where like say you're at on
the analytics team at Airbnb and you
already have a lot of users and you're
just trying to optimize that experience
right and so for a start-up figure that
out first and then if you need one from
day one hire one from day one if you get
a machine learning engineer in the door
who really that's their forte you're
gonna be better set up for success
instead of trying to sort of you know
kind of hawk it and that and then have
to kind of catch up later
because often you don't know what you
don't know and you might not be tracking
the right data or you're not and you're
not sort of setting things up you're
infrastructure in a way that's gonna
help you scale later and then those
there's especially in products where
machine learning is critical that
becomes challenging mm-hm
one thing I recommend to startups
actually is talk to just just talk to
folks in the industry and frankly get an
advisor right if you're not ready to
hire data scientist yet at least maybe
think about getting on a data science
adviser because they're gonna be able to
sit where do you find this yeah good
question
so free email me yeah yeah no I mean
you'd be surprised a lot of I mean maybe
some of the top folks who started the
data science team at like LinkedIn you
know that's not that's that's hard to
get into but you know I think even any
sort of data scientist have been in the
field who knows what they're doing will
be able to sit with a founder and say
listen you're probably gonna want to
instrument these features to collect
this data because you're gonna want to
analyze this later or here's the type of
work you want done probably down the
road so if you want someone to help you
understand how to lay the groundwork to
actually do that hire
you guys start off with eight students
in that first class can you talk about
where it is right now like students are
you processing now and then also like
what is different about the curriculum
program yeah yeah so it's definitely
scaled up a bit since then we're now in
five cities so San Francisco New York
Boston Seattle Toronto my hometown just
launched it this year which is fun and
we've got a bunch of different
specializations now so data science is
one data engineering health data AI
we're even sort of doing product
management now helping product managers
transition to AI so overall were we do
three sessions a year it's like almost
like you have different classes
depending on where you're starting on on
the specializations yeah because the the
fields specialized right it used to be
like you just hire a data scientist who
you hope will take care of everything
and now you you want folks who are
building infrastructure the data
engineers you want the data scientists
who are sort of laying building the
early prototypes and figuring out what
to build and then more often not now you
need machine learning engineers to
really kind of put that into production
now and so you see these different
specializations and we had essentially
have a program for each so the data
science programs for PhDs because that
sort of scientific experience is
critical
the AI program for instances for PhD has
been predominately for engineers
actually who are going to machine
learning engineering roles and how
bigger these classes so there are so
overall across all the cities and
programs we're at about 300 or just over
300 fellows per session now but each
program is small so we keep it sort of
maximum 20 to 30 35 fellows and because
the idea is each one of those sub that's
right I programs in each location
because you want that the collaboration
is critical you want that group to sort
of gel everybody's working on a project
you want it you want people kind of
tapping each other on the shoulder
asking for help
you want that alumni who's coming in to
be able to kind of sit with the fellows
so long as the small groups really are
critical for that how long seven weeks
and then super file so what gets done in
seven weeks yeah so it's pretty
incredible how fast people learn and
what they build so literally you know
they'll go from in Week one trying to
come up with the idea or partnering with
a start-up so often fellows work with
startups
a partnership with YC so brought them to
get good they start with a project
well week once figure out what project
so like your first week is like should I
come up with something on my own and
build it based on advice I'm getting
from our alumni from our mentors or our
team or should I go partner with a YC
startup he's got a data challenge that
they want solved and so that's step one
is figure out what you're building and
figure out what and again a fearow
problem you're playing in the next
couple weeks you better build it fast so
folks have to go from literally nothing
to like an MVP and you know week or two
I didn't then they're out presenting the
antenna me you week time they're working
individually because they're trying to
show that they're able to kind of
execute end to end on a real-world
problem but it's incredibly
collaborative so if you come to insight
it's like it's it doesn't look like a
classroom it looks like kind of like a
startup office and everybody's just kind
of at desks sitting together and people
are on whiteboards they talk to each
other helping each other because you
know you encounter the same problems
technical otherwise and it's that
collaborative aspect that allows people
to move super fast and learn a ton and
and if you're in the program or you're
just checking out the program maybe
applying for jobs like this yeah what
are the types of projects that you
recommend of voiding hmm you know things
that people have seen a hundred times
before yeah I recommend like our people
happy on Twitter is like that's maybe
done that is a good general a general
example because there's people been
doing like this the more kind of I think
useful example is make something useful
right so I think it's really easy to
just be like I took this algorithm that
used to operate at 99.1 percent and now
accuracy and now I'm gonna make it
nineteen two point three like you know
and I don't know why but like it's
better now right or what you see
scientists sometimes do is this very
generic like I studied you know here
I'll give you an example of a project I
loved that I felt come up but you know
so here's the bad version here's the
version someone did at insight but you
can do it up you know do this at home so
the bad version so let's say the topic
solar panels you want to understand
solar panel usage and really enable
people to adopt solar panels bad project
is and I analyzed general trends about
solar panel usage in California
it's like look at this interesting fact
I found about it's like okay whatever
right maybe for an analyst report that's
interesting but not for actually get
anything done to me it's like it has no
call to action exact like you want it to
be almost opinionated because that way a
business knows is like oh I can look at
this know what don't know what to do
exactly right I think the bad projects
are the ones feels like oh no I have
homework that's right oh here's some
problem I have with a lot of like
analytic services yeah all you do is
like just tell me yeah that's why I
don't know anything yeah but now I still
don't know what to do so I've paid to be
the whole figure stuff out whether feels
dumb exactly and so the good version of
this project which is a fellow didn't is
one of my favorites is I'm a homeowner
should I buy solar or not will solar be
profitable on a roof okay that's a hard
problem what's the weather like what's
the I mean a ton of different factors
press there's some predict as some
predictive aspects of all that all this
the fellow took all this data
synthesized it build a predictive model
I come in I type in my address it tells
me whether I should buy solar oh they
base me but yeah so all these all these
projects are very product focused
they're so product focus that sometimes
companies are like why are you showing
us products when like we just want data
scientists and the answer is because
that demonstrates that people can think
product wise and and they end up loving
it because they sort of abstractly don't
understand why they're showing us
products but but people gravitate to
real solutions and then hold it yeah
they hire the fellows well so this is
related to something we talked about the
other day which is like in the future
are more data scientists going to become
founders or is that like personality
that mentality like is that best suited
within a big company oh really yeah it's
not gonna be kids like designers who've
like for some reason designers don't
tend to become founders you know
we'll see how it shapes up in terms of
like is it gonna be on mass data
scientists but certainly I would say a
probably about a quarter of every
fellows program I I see like raise their
hand when they say they want to start a
company in the next five years
[ __ ] yeah yeah and so and so I think
that's going to be a big thing we've
already seen some of our
alumni start companies although again
it's early in the early difficut
diana wu was in one of the early session
started trace genomics a genomics
company which uses genomic data to tell
farmers when to plant when not to plan
super interesting not an alumni but like
an early mentor Ben Kamen's used to be
the kind of founding engineer at Khan
Academy hmm and he hired one of our
fellows Lauren who is a physicist she
went there helped them sort of you know
help impact a bunch of hopefully impact
a bunch of kids lives led by like
helping them learn faster yes they
really have millions of data points of
data on how people learn and she was
there for fewers with been helping with
education and now Ben went off yeah I
mentioned Ben because he's very much
kind of a data scientist at heart yeah
and although he found her you know his
titles officially CTO he went off and
found its spring discovery now they're
doing sort of helping age aging related
diseases using machine learning to do
that Lauren went over there with him
sort of part of the founding team and so
you know again more you know TBD in
terms of like what the stats are gonna
be in terms of founders but that founder
spirit is there and the skill set is so
easy I mean that's the thing like
regardless having an understanding of
product is like the pinnacle absolute
you can go absolute cuz whether you're
employee whether you're founder employee
10 or 100 or frankly a thousand you
better you better know what what and so
do you teach that as well oh yeah it's
one of the biggest things I mean how do
you teach it you know I found the only
way teaches by doing yeah so you say
like build the product and then they
don't they give you a graph that shows
me interesting things that you say no no
like no like yeah and you iterate you
just iterate yeah I mean that's the
learning experience you do it wrong and
then you iterate and you fix it and get
better and so the model at insight is
really just continual feedback so if at
the end of the program I tell you like
no that's wrong then that's a bad
learning experience but at insite you'll
be told like half a day in that that's
like not the way to go and by the like
next half day you'll be closer there and
by the first week you'll you'll
hopefully be on a good path
building a cool products is that fast
iteration if you cool I think one of the
things that ends up being a problem for
a lot of startups or for even people
getting into the data science field is
like they're encountering very dirty
data and so now a lot of time actually
is like this is not like oh I'm solving
cool problems I'm making products it's
like oh I'm just being sitting here
cleaning up yeah this day just so I can
get to this point
yeah and so I'm trying to figure out is
that is this something that did a
scientist need to beware of that you're
just gonna walk into this and there's
something like startups need to start
thinking about and about like what can
they do to like prevent that both but I
think you could never avoid it so it
really is the data scientist job to be
prepared for that to be to do well at
that and that's what is they what's the
ratio of the job of like mining versus
like there's this joke like 90% of the
job is data cleaning I don't know if
it's 90 but it's a lot and it's not just
data kleenex data cleaning sounds kind
of lame like you're just kind of
cleaning things up yeah it's it's I
think more interesting than that it's
like literally like what data even makes
sense to get here it's not obviously in
advance you think it's obvious you're
like I'll just throw some data what data
of what and how can you combine that
data and what does it mean to have clean
relevant data and give an apple that's a
skill set well you know I'll have you I
have an example around the founder side
right so I think founders often makes
the the sort of assumption that they're
tracking all the right things and then
we've had many experiences where you
know we'll talk to a founder of fellows
gonna work with like a founder and
they'll say yeah I've got all the day
they we got everything right a big data
big data yeah it's all its data and then
you know and then you you open it up and
it's like oh [ __ ] they didn't track user
logins like which user was logging in
they're tracking on all the movements on
the site yeah but not which movement
which user was use doing that and at
what time stamp and again it it's like
oh my god like like all this data is
borderline unusable because we can't
kind of peg it to specific behavior and
model that behavior and you know it when
you're looking at from the data
perspective it sounds like hilarious
like it why don't you track users yeah
but you know what I'm a founder I know
it when you're a founder you're thinking
about a million
different things yeah have a million
different trade-offs and honestly like
yeah the Logging's turn on like let's go
right let's build let's and then a year
later you're regretting that so again I
think a lesson learned for sure that's
why it's like hey have a coffee with the
data scientist like maybe all you'll get
it from it is like log your user logins
but that might be enough and then and
then a year later you can get started
with the data scientist what's the best
tools that people should do for tracking
data or like is there a product yeah
that sort of should use just write it
again that you wrote that if they do
this we're just gonna start on I guess
so
you know honestly I saw some the
questions on Twitter and I know you know
folks always ask about tools so I was
actually actually asking around some my
team like hey like what's the latest on
this and there are great tools I think
for just sort of like basic analytic
tracking or like websites but if you're
really building products like it's still
to this day we see the team's roll their
own hmm because there's so much there's
so much such a disappoint it is a
disappointing answer and I think you
know listen there are companies working
on it some YC companies and they're
slowly progressing up to more
sophisticated sort dat price but at the
end of the day if you're lifeblood is a
very specific product that does
something very specific like there's
like nothing beats just having somebody
very thoughtfully say what do we
actually care about tracking here ok so
they're tracking how soon back then yeah
like assuming they're there is no easy
answer then your founder yeah you just
started you're saying yeah can you give
me like five or ten things that I should
be tracking well I mean it really
depends on the company right ok fine so
so I I think the the number one thing
you have to think about as a founder is
actually not even what you're tracking
because honestly if you think about this
first thing right
I think that'll become more obvious yeah
the first thing you got to think about I
think about it right is what are you
actually trying to optimize what's the
one or two metrics you actually care
about what if you're thinking about
machine learning and building predictive
models like say you had a mission magic
machine learning model that like did
whatever you want but you only had one
or two with which problem your company
would you would you apply to because I
think what I see folks do is oh I know
my business in and out and so on so I I
know my metric is this this this this
this this and this
and then oma Xin learning will build
this this this is this and you know what
you might at some point down the road
but initially you're gonna have to focus
and if you don't have that focus that's
where you get into this habit of I'll
just track everything or nothing whereas
if you know what you're trying to
optimize is let's say let's say I'm
Netflix yeah yeah what am I going to
start tracking oh I mean you're you're
you obviously want to see how how long
people are watching the video how far
they get in that video we one of the
teams they're less obvious is people are
using different devices on different
bandwidths so they tracked I mean they
test this stuff and track it on all
sorts of different different machines so
again like if in a generic in a generic
tool would you have a situation where
you're testing like a stream on a
hundred different devices and on no you
wouldn't because like if that's not
court of your business why would you
ever do that right but if you're now
flicks you better be doing that and
because you know that user experience is
the key right Khan Academy is something
different right for Khan Academy it's
like you know maybe it's the amount of
time kids are spending on a question and
that's telling you something about
whether they're learning we're on
another site it's like you don't really
care about the timing you just care
about the flow so for understanding for
any startup and most companies it's like
always like my goal is growth yeah and
for us how I see we've actually pretty
much simplified it where it's just like
look for the most part your KPI that
your company is actually interested in
driving it's either going to be revenue
right and that's like ninety nine
percent of the company yeah and for some
like consumer very difficult play is
like I'm going after engagement like
sure Kayleigh active users that the
ideal sometimes its weekly active users
that's just the nature of the Mirada and
so to me it's just like okay what drives
those two things are really just like
only two numbers it's like conversion
and then like churn yeah and so I
imagine like most questions fall into
those two cats like what increases
conversion for a revenue oh and what
reduces trend for revenue and the same
thing for like engagement so those are
so i'll maybe i'll speak directly to
those because now you're kind of zeroing
in on certain types of companies and so
for turn we often have fellows built
churn prediction models for startups so
again they they're there
demise because there's I mean turn it
turned for what what's happening yet but
when we're talking about churn it's a
customer deciding to stop using the
product and if we can predict that ahead
of time then they're able to intervene
maybe offer a discount maybe engage that
user get feedback so those are top the
list and for conversion experimentation
is the key it's like these
experimentation frameworks always feel
like a lot of times startups especially
earlier early ones they neglect that
whole churn question because I always
tell them is like look you're obsessed
about conversion right cuz you're in
salesman trying to bring them in but I
think it's always feel like it's very
expensive and I feel like improving
churn like improving term by the same
percentage that's exactly same thing for
card but it's way easier keyword set
setups with and so is that usually what
the first projects that startups and
companies should be looking at if they
haven't at all absolutely great and you
know you know one thing a lot about
churn is it's often more reflective of
what is actually working or not working
right it's like making people want it's
like if you improve turn that means
you're you're truly understanding what
the user wants maybe you can get them to
sign up or convert just by sort of you
know having a flashy sales pitch but
churn really you understand it and then
that's where the exploratory data
analysis comes in do you really
understand what your users doing that's
where the a be testing and often what's
called like multi-armed bandit testing
where you're trying various different
experiments at once that's where you're
predicting churn and then trying to
intervene to to help the customer but
it's you see what I'm saying it's like
it's like a number of different things
all of which are grounded in do I
understand what my user wants and am i
building building to what what they
really care about I think the other big
trend that you're having people sort of
obsessed with metrics wise is like
cohorts and like retention curves over
time and so what are usually like the
best things people should do like yes
Jim understanding and knowing it and
like that sometimes really difficult but
in terms of improving that like where
does data science usually help right I
mean I I think it's it's coming back to
turn right because if you're if you're
seeing folks drop off at month three and
like you're your early cohorts I mean I
mean that's a term problem right there
so yeah I think it goes back to churn a
lot of those sort of dashboards are you
know are are you know there are great
tools for those so certainly like when I
started people with like hand code like
cohort analysis
now there's a bunch of tools for that so
I'm not saying so certainly I think in
the metrics sort of dashboard domain
there's a lot of solutions when I was
saying that there isn't really a
ready-made solution it's more it's more
that stuff that's that's kind of where
it's you're actually building models to
improve the product in a very sort of
deep way you guys have a favorite
further like because you said that good
starts have good problems yeah are you
waiting for a sponsorship I'm trying to
understand like some tool that you - no
honestly at in site almost everybody
just easy open-source right so I
reasonable - you know yeah it's all the
open source and because that's actually
what's we're seeing reflected in the
industry so if you go to a top data
science team by far and away the vast
majority of what they're using a
building on is open source what are the
what are those projects like I think
Python is definitely it used to be like
Python and they're still building it
themselves
yeah yeah absolutely yeah right and then
they just use like what Jupiter
notebooks like that for prototyping and
then and then you gotta then start
building then you roll your own and then
you roll your own and frankly at that
point as soon as you get away as soon as
you get past the prototyping stage you
you're really just building product
right it's the same thing an engineering
team does it straight right it's like
what tools are they using to build the
fundamental product and no and and
that's where you're that's where you're
living those data scientists are often
embedded with the team
they'll be directly who makes the base
best data science like from what film
have you noticed we're like oh this much
better that they come from this field
what's kind of been shot one of your
favorite children what I was a I was
accused of you know I'm for physics so
now you know there's we have fellows
from all different backgrounds so they
all succeed no I mean I think that's
been the the shocking thing is like how
different the backgrounds are we have a
fellow in this session his as an
archaeology PhD we had a fellow a
session ago it was like an engineer at
like space axe right like we had
imagined each other so we have similar
systems like you got like a
mathematician exactly we're going to get
the math understand the particle but
selling themselves and understand
problems probably does exactly so so
often you'll find like a mathematician
is great for instance I've made great
data engineers because they think about
large-scale systems and how
can they fail I mean in Malthus logic
systems but any kind of transfer that
that sort of mode of thinking to data
infrastructure but someone like for
instance psychology was one that like in
the early days I didn't really have a
network in kind of psychology and or
neuroscience so we did a lot of work to
try to kind of put the word out there we
found social scientists are incredible
data scientists quite often because they
know how to write question and they know
how to think about people and ultimately
you know obviously data is branching out
but most of the time you're when you're
talking about users you're talking about
customers it's people right and so
fantastic data scientist from those
fields but it's just one of my favorite
parts my job actually is the fact that
I'll you sit at lunch or a happy hour or
just hang out at the office and it's
like an astrophysicist with a
psychologist with a software engineer
with a you know electrical engineer and
they're all kind of working
collaborating and it's just incredible
incredible kind of environment to be
around all these different people you
have all these companies coming in
talking with all your students during
the program and they're usually coming
like with a problem or they just talking
about here's the kind of problems we
work on and solved because they're kind
of doing a little bit of recruiting in
addition to giving an understanding
absolutely yeah yeah and it was really
great at that we we have I mean what do
they do that's really there's a bunch of
teams you know listen I think so the way
the program works is fellows will often
work with a startup company on a project
but the most of the most of the
interactions of the fellows have with
companies is actually companies coming
in to try and hire them right and when I
say companies I mean like the actual
technical data team coming in talking
about what they work on yeah and but you
know and trying to hire them and so the
the teams that do really well listen
obviously the ones with great brands the
Airbnb is the list the ubers the
Facebook I don't know what the little
guys have to compete with them but this
is what I found is when startups come in
what often happens is fellows coming
what's this startup I don't know heard
of that why do I have to go to this and
they come out they're like this is my
dream job I want to look at this company
and I started trying to figure out what
certain startups did to do that and what
it really boils down to is impact the
startups that do well
recruiting data scientists make the
pitch you are critical to our success if
we if they main it's like they're gonna
be all stars and and and they're telling
the truth because that a lot of
companies these days frankly if the
machine learning or if the Analects
doesn't work like the company will fail
like that's what they're pitching well
also when there's one of you versus 300
of you right well that's a personality
thing right some people are excited
about I'm gonna be the first data
scientist and some people are like I
want I want I want some mentorship a lot
I need a little motor on me yeah yeah
but when it comes to like I've never
heard of this company before and then an
hour later like oh my god I want to work
for that it's always the impact piece
it's always the like if you come here
what you do will matter in a big way and
obviously there's the technical piece
you're gonna work on cool stuff yeah but
I thought the technical piece would be
the biggest one but the biggest one
actually is the impact for sure Oh
so one thing we haven't talked about and
I actually don't know if you have an
opinion on this isn't contracting so for
an average startup say they're like a
couple years in I don't know if we
really have a need for this but we have
all this data maybe we could put it to
use do you see people like doing
two-month contracts and getting a system
up and then just letting it go what
happens yeah I think contracting is good
for prototyping so we see a lot of like
what I'm saying why see startups work
with our fellows that's essentially it's
a pro bono controlled consult thing but
they're working with them for you know
the program yeah I think to deliver some
results and where that works really well
is you know often is integrated but it's
at this sort of prototyping stage
well this even work like or I've got a
model well this one work better okay if
we try this so let me give you an
example of one I really like recently a
fellow work with ISO no health why see
startup really amazing product as like
sort of in-home breast cancer screening
so it's a device instead of going once a
year to get screened for breast cancer
if you're in high risk you can do it at
home secondly using leading cause of
cancer death and women so huge impact
potentially life-saving technology and
obviously a big part of that is can we
do we have the right algorithms to
detect and notify a user that hey you
need to go speak to your doctor or
notify a doctor obviously a doctor does
the the the final thing but is there
something abnormal here that
to be taking a closer look at they had
algorithms that were working great and
doing well for them especially at that
stage of hey let's just bring it to a
doctor to be safe but they were curious
about hey are some of these more like
these newest sort of deep learning
algorithms that could just coming out in
the papers are they going to do better
for us so a fellow did that they took
the data and essentially use some brand
new sort of convolutional neural network
techniques that have just kind of been
published and got better results for
them that we're almost on par with sort
of expert radiologists and so I mean
that's that's awesome right and and so
of course that team then has to do some
more work to implement it but that
that's an example where I think
consulting works is like is this gonna
work is this is this feasible as a
prototype anytime you actually I think
then kind of anytime that becomes a part
of your product you need a team right
because it's never static some
something's gonna evolve and change and
you need to be able to evolve it it's
something it's just like asking like can
a start-up just have like contract
software engineers overseas it's like
well maybe to prototype something but in
general probably answer's no because
that that products gonna keep evolving
every month every year and you need
focus on the stuff to do it makes sense
to me
great cool um so I think one last thing
I wanted to talk about was just areas
you're excited about in particular yeah
we mentioned health the other day yeah
but yeah what's exciting to you right
now in the field no I mean I'll there's
a bunch of stuff that's excited me but
but a health health is the top one that
I'm pumped about because it I mean the
impacts there right like then what the
example I just shared with you I mean
early detection disease monitoring I
mean literally saving people's lives as
this stuff works and what's interesting
is people have been talking about the
impact in data science machine learning
and health for it for years because you
know you start thinking about this stuff
and pretty quickly or like this could
make an impact but you know the the the
actually getting into work is tough and
only I think in the last few years we've
been seeing a lot of teams actually
making really amazing progress there
I'll give you an example I love of like
the impact here
Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Hospital
in New York
has hired out at a team of data science
data engineers from us over the last few
years and what they do is they build
essentially data products but that are
used internally by their doctors so
these are cancer doctors really tough
situations and they're faced with a
situation of what clinical trials do I
recommend to my to my patient and
there's thousands of clinical trials and
there's new ones coming online every day
which one do you suggest and so they're
building these kind of data products
where the doctor gets based on the
specific personalized
you know whether it's genomic or
clinical factors hey you should at least
think about these new clinical trials
that are coming online and again the
doctor makes the final decision but it's
but it's hey maybe one of those trials
they hadn't heard about now say that
that patient's life right and it's it's
passing it's a whole stuff that it's a
hospital since I write and then and then
soon thereafter new york-presbyterian
hired a fellow and then Mount Sinai
hired a fellow and and now pharma
companies are hiring fellows and then
it's it's really fascinating to see data
broaden now when companies realize that
they can just take it beyond oh I want
to optimize this like business and
efficiency and really think what can I
create that's gonna add incredible value
and so health is what I'm excited but
there's there's there's a ton more out
there yeah that's super cool all right
well thanks for coming in thanks so much
thanks Trey
you